Lực lượng vũ trang thuy điện và bà Lan mới đây đã phối hợp tụi tập trận mang tên
Gotland Centuries, chính đào Gotland VGT cho được trung tâm biển bàn tích
của tập trận có sự tham gia của bình sĩ thuイ điện, lượng lượng lĩnh sống và đơn vị
tên lượng bà biển của bà Lan với một tiêu kiểm tra khả năng chính khai nhanh và phản nướng
trương quyết cơ bị tấn công. Góc lần được có là tổng sân bay dự biển nhớ kiểm soất
tối nạn hải quan trọng, đã biển nếu nât tô cần tiếp viển cho các nước màn tích
Hôm đào, giải mua chăm bẩy mấy nè từ bi phí quân số hoa sau chính trình lại
Nhưng tự nằm anh in không chăm mấy tấm, tuy điện đã tải mua chang
khôi vụ trung đàn Gotland và chiến khai khảy thống phòng thủy nè đại
Biển tuy điện chính thương sân nhập nât tô nằm anh in không chóa mít tư
căn lâm ra tăng giá chỉ chính lợg của Gotland
Bột tập trận là nè tập trung cùng có khả năng phối ước tắt chiến dưới thuy điện và bà Lan
và cũng như khẳng định quyết tâm bà về anh nình khu vực bàn tích